all right so I alluded to this earlier
you have to see the level of chaos that
the mark Meadows Trump Riot texts are
causing in right-wing media so let me
reset the story for you first and then
we're going to just jump into something
I I it's it's genuinely delightful I
don't know how else to describe it
earlier this week Republican
congresswoman Liz Cheney member of the
house uh committee investigating the
January 6 riots read a bunch of text
messages
reportedly sent from Fox News hosts and
Donald Trump Jr to Trump's then Chief of
Staff Mark Meadows and despite going on
air that day and for weeks downplaying
the riots it might have been antifa it
was BLM it wasn't real Trump supporters
I didn't actually see any Trump
supporter being violent as well as
Trump's own son and all of these Fox
News hosts doing that on that day they
knew it was terrible and they knew it
was Trump's problem and they were trying
to get Trump on TV to make a statement
tell him to send everybody home it
exposes that everything they did after
the fact was just dishonest cleanup and
they knew exactly who was there that day
and that it was very bad for Donald
Donald Trump period they knew it they
lied on TV to help Trump no surprise
it's been confirmed now all of the
different factions are starting to go at
each other because they don't know how
to manage this last night Sean Hannity
one of the people implicated in this
entire Fiasco had a segment where he
invited on Geraldo Rivera and this total
right-wing nut Dan bongino who just
defends Trump always and forever there's
no situation where bongino won't defend
Trump and Geraldo even though he you
know was a trump supporter is a friend
of trump whatever Geraldo actually
stands up sort of for what's right and
says to Hannity listen
because Hannity's continuing to downplay
the riots he says this was a riot
it was inspired by Trump supporters
period and Hannity tries to interrupt
and her also says wait a second Sean
think back to when you sent those texts
think back to your frame of mind when
you realized these are trumpists doing
this and this is violent and this is
terrible and you texted Mark Meadows
think back to that and bongino just
loses it on Geraldo check this out
because the obvious difference between
the riot that happened on January 6th
and the 500 odd that you correctly cite
as concerning and and and damaging to
America to our psyche to our our
physical well-being is that this was a
riot that was Unleashed incited and
inspired by the president of the United
States which targeted
American democracy the president didn't
say no you could that targeted the
president said Peace no no stop the
president said peacefully patriotically
March the capital that's your opinion I
don't even want to go down that road
that's not the question tonight the
question is this corrupt committee the
question is why this Riot and not 574
other rights the question is is there
any privacy in this country anymore or
do they get to release thousands more of
individual private citizens tax
I beg you Sean to remember the
frame of mind you were in when you wrote
that text on January 6th and when Laura
did and when Brian did and when Don Jr
did remember the concern you had
remember the the frustration
at our our beloved 45th president
to be doing this why doesn't he say
something why okay the point is he did
you saw unfolding before you he saw
unfolding before your very eyes and
attack on Democracy attack on the
Constitution
he said peacefully and then he did do it
Dan you have less than a minute we're
running out of time Geraldo we've been
arguing about this forever the
backstabbing of the president you're
engaging in is really disgusting and
it's really vile that you pretend to be
this guy
I resent that Jesus
democracy let me respond he abandoned
the election on results and he refused
March peacefully he refused to accept
the will of the American people you
heard it nobody can hear you you heard
it leave it there and you stab them in
the back you heard it thank you thank
you both so it's not backstabbing it's
telling the truth Geraldo is saying
nothing controversial it was a trumpist
riot Sean Hannity knew it and texted
Mark Meadows at the time to try to stop
it and now he's playing a completely
different version of events on TV day in
and day out that's really it like
there's no more story and Hannity pulls
in bongino to run interference and
they're starting to just go after each
other Heraldo is no Sage right when
Geraldo is the voice of reason you know
things have gotten a little bit wacky
but this is what you want to see this
committee has already done so much good
in all that it is exposed and all these
people are more than willing to go after
each other to save themselves remember
that if Republicans had just gone along
with the original committee
it is far less likely that all of this
same damaging information would have
come out why do I say that well the
original committee idea was I believe
these are the right numbers five
Democrats five Republicans when they
would send out subpoenas the subpoenas
would have to be signed off on not only
by the Democratic chair of the committee
but by the Republican Vice chair of the
committee it was going to be truly a
committee that was not just going to
have carte blanche to go fishing
wherever they want Republicans uh and
I'm not saying that that's what it is
now but Republicans said we're not going
to participate we're protesting this
entire thing unless we're also looking
into you know the shooting of Steve
scalise four years ago or whatever else
we don't want to participate so Nancy
Pelosi found some Republicans willing to
be on it Liz Cheney's on it Adam
kinzinger is on it don't remember if
there's any other Republicans but at
least the two of them and now you have a
situation in which they by virtue of
Republicans saying we're basically
opting out of this thing and at least at
the party level we don't support it even
if you found a couple of our people to
be on this committee now they are
actually doing really good work and
exposing incredible things there was a
PowerPoint for the coup
all these people who for months have
been doing media saying it wasn't what
it was on that day knew exactly what it
was and we're texting Mark Meadows and
saying please help to stop it so it's
excellent that the committee is doing
this it's exactly the type of insight
infighting and Bedlam that we want to
see within the Republican Party bongino
Hannity Geraldo you have them all
fighting that's exactly what we want
they will turn on each other to protect
themselves that's abundantly clear if
you say hey the riot was inspired by
Trump which obviously it was they
accused their own of backstabbing and
Geraldo is or was a trumpet I mean he
makes it clear even in that segment the
difference is that Hannity and vangino
will never admit that Trump did anything
wrong Geraldo will admit it and he'll
still say he is or was my friend and I
did or do support him it takes nearly 80
year old Geraldo Rivera to apparently
realize that what took place on January
6th was not just partisan bickering or a
rally it was something much darker and
much more Sinister and hopefully this
level of chaos will continue
one of our sponsors is athletic greens
which makes comprehensive daily
nutrition really simple people are busy
we're not always getting effective
balanced nutrition from the food we eat
we sometimes are combining all sorts of
different vitamins supplements different
things that may be relevant to us ag1 by
athletic greens is a delicious drink
that just simplifies the entire thing
it's one product you get all of the
things you need 75 vitamins minerals and
Whole Food sourced ingredients it's a
multivitamin it's a multi-mineral it's a
probiotic green food blend in one daily
serving really easy high quality bio
available ingredients can fill those
nutritional gaps in your diet and they
can help with gut health and digestion
and support you in other ways and they
can replace multiple products and pills
that you might be taking it's just one
drink really simple I've been enjoying
the ag1 drink by athletic greens tastes
good helps me get everything I'm trying
to get athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin D and five free travel packs
with your first purchase when you go to
athletic greens.com Pacman the link is
in the podcast notes